Pretty hard to understand PageSpeed
Insights and related components.
Any advice?
Okay, yeah.
So, PageSpeed Insight does
sometimes give you these sort of,
I guess,
vague problems about your website.
They might just say, you know,
eliminate render blocking CSS or
eliminate render blocking JavaScript.
And then it kind of gives you some
hints on what that means, but
it never really gives you a clear
guideline on, okay, go and fix this.
So I would say the first thing
to do is to definitely read what
PageSpeed Insights gives you as
information about those things.
Then go back and look at your code and
see if you can pick out any parts of
your code that sort of match
with what they've described.
For example, if you have render blocking
CSS that means that you have components
in your CSS that are preventing
your entire page from rendering.
So you need to go and
look at what particular CSS script
is the one that's causing
this render blocking.
You can kind of do that by
taking them out one at a time or
you can come up with some
clever ways to do that.
Do you have any insights on
the best way to interpret and
use PageSpeed Insights, Turner?
>> Yeah, that's great advice John.
And, if you ever have a question about
something you can also Google for
the exact phrase and you'll probably
find a wealth of extra pages
on minimizing the critical
rendering path, beside and
in addition to what you
learned in the course.
So, that never hurts in
case you're extra curious,
but a lot of times,
hopefully it does refer to
new terminology that
you've learned of course.
But when it doesn't, certainly just go
look it up and see if it's applicable,
learn a new thing here and there.
>> Can we load different images with
different compression levels while using
different devices or
different screen resolutions.
[LAUGH]
>> But that way it's going to be
taking responsive images and
wants to really optimize this.
>> The answer to that is absolutely,
yes you can.
So it's a little trickier.
You have to utilize, CSS to
serve the appropriate images as opposed
to hard coding them in your HTML.
You can also do it with JavaScript but
I prefer using CSS to render
those kinds of images.
And then while using different devices
with different screen resolution, yeah,
you're going to have to look into using
media queries for that kind of stuff.
And serving your images
with media queries and CSS.
In terms of actually creating
all these different images for
all these different devices and
different screen resolutions,
if you haven't looked at the responsive
images course yet, you totally should.
Cameron breaks down how to use
task runners like Grunt, for
example, to automate all of this.
And you don't have to sit there and
tweak a bunch of images by
hand in some photo editor hoping
that they're rendered correctly.
Different events on the page that
change the render tree would cause
a new layout event each time.
We could increase or speed, supposedly,
by using batch updates
according to the video.
Yeah, so Liam, what this means is,
we can create these JavaScript
events that basically manipulate
our DOM or our render tree.
And the more times we call those events,
the more times we're
re-accessing the DOM,
changing something, and
then redrawing the tree.
Basically creating a new
layout event each time.
What they mean by batch updates is,
you want to create basically a function
or some sort of methods that do as
much of this as possible without
accessing the DOM multiple times.
A good way to do this is when you
access a DOM, the DOM elements,
you actually put those in a variable and
then you manipulate that variable.
And that way you only call the up
document object model once.
And then you make all the changes you
want and then all the updates happen.
And then the layout event happens.
because every time you take
requests from the DOM,
it has to process all those
changes that have been previously.
And, so you'll actually notice
this in the pizza page.
For example, with the moving
pieces in the background.
Pay close attention to how many times
you're actually accessing your document
object model.
Because it's a lot, and if you can
reduce the number of times that that
query selector is selecting everything,
the faster you're page is going to load,
and you'll be amazed at how much faster,
too.
It literally goes from a couple
seconds to a couple milliseconds.
>> Do we not care about frames
per second for page loading.
>> Yes, so this thing is,
there are two fixes that you
have to do in your main.js file.
If you had read the comments,
Cameron has given you that.
There are two fixes to do in main.js,
and they are completely pertaining
how you scroll through through the page
and how the pizza sizes changes.
And how the background pizzas
move around in the page.
So, whenever you scroll up and down you
can see the background pizzas moving.
So, that is one area where there
is a major fix to be carried out.
So for this project and for
this particular solution we
are only looking for
scrolling over the page, up and
down the page, and
then resizing the pizzas.
So, yeah,
you should only worry about that,
don't be too concerned
about page loading.